o la pandemia no da tregua en rusia por
primera vez en la última jornada
registró más de mil muertes la cifra más
alta de decesos por kobe 19 en la nación
europea el país con una de las puntas 5
lleva semanas batiendo sus propios
récords de fallecimientos y contagios
entretanto se redobla la presión sobre
el sistema sanitario fútbol
decidimos aprovechar las entregas de
oxígeno a las industrias con el fin de
hacer una reserva es necesario para los
hospitales un bajo índice de vacunación
explica el repunte aunque el país
desarrolló varias vacunas las cifras de
inmunización no han cumplido las
expectativas del gobierno que anima a
los ciudadanos a aplicarse las dosis las
cadenas de televisión del país llevan a
cabo una intensa campaña con ese
objetivo estos nuestros nervios socios
somos no vascular me fue irresponsable
de mi parte si pudiera ir hacia atrás me
vacunaría no bebo no fumo hago ejercicio
en la mañana y camino de 5 a 7
kilómetros pero todo ello no sirve para
nada sin vacunación como lo pueden ver
hasta el momento tan sólo un 30% de la
población ha recibido las dos dosis del
suero nacional sputnik 5 en parte porque
existe un escepticismo generalizado
sobre esta y otras vacunas en el último
reporte diario más de 33 mil nuevos
contagios fueron detectados y aunque
algunas regiones toman medidas para
preparar los hospitales el gobierno es
reticente a imponer nuevas cuarentenas
grandes ciudades como la capital auto
moscú-san petersburgo siguen operando
prácticamente con total normalidad